Now this looks like an
interesting problem.
We have this polygon.
It looks like a pentagon right
over here, has five sides.
It's an irregular pentagon.
Not all the sides look
to be the same length.
And the sides are
kind of continued on.
And we have these
particular exterior angles
of this pentagon.
And what we're asked
is, what is the sum
of all of these exterior angles.
And it's kind of daunting,
because they don't give us
any other information.
They don't even give us
any particular angles.
They don't start
us off anywhere.
And so what we can
do, let's just think
about the step by step, just
based on what we do know.
Well, we have these
exterior angles.
And these exterior
angles, they're
each supplementary to
some interior angle.
So maybe if we can
express them as a function
of the interior angles, we
can maybe write this problem
in a way that seems a
little bit more doable.
So let's write the
interior angles over here.
We already got to e.
So let's call this f,
this interior angle f.
Let's call this
interior angle g.
interior angle h.
Let's call this one i.
And let's call this one j.
And so this sum of these
particular exterior angles, a
is now the same
thing as 180 minus g,
because a and g
are supplementary.
So a is 180 minus g.
And then we have plus b.
But b we can write in terms
of this interior angle.
It's going to be 180 minus h,
because these two angles once
again, are supplementary.
We do that in a new color.
So this is going
to be 180 minus h.
And we could do the same
thing for each of them. c,
we can write as 180 minus
i, so plus 180 minus i.
And then d, we can write as 180
minus j, so plus 180 minus j.
And then finally, e, I'm
running out of colors,
e, we can write as 180 minus
f, so plus 180 minus f.
And so, what we're left with,
if we add up all the 180s,
we have 180 5 times.
So this is going to be equal to
5 times 180 which is what, 900.
And then you have minus g, minus
h, minus i, minus j, minus f.
Or we could write
that as minus-- I'll
try to do the same
colors-- g plus h--
I'm kind of factoring out
this negative sign-- g
plus h-- I'll do
the same color as g,
that's not the same color-- g
plus h, plus i, plus j, plus f.
And the whole
reason why did this
and why this is
interesting now, is
that we've expressed
this first thing
that we need to figure out.
We've expressed it in terms
of sum of the interior angles.
So it's going to be 900
minus all of this business.
So this is 900 minus all
of this business, which
is the sum of the
interior angles.
So this is the sum of
the interior angles.
So it seems like we've made a
little progress, at least if we
can figure out the sum
of the interior angles.
And to do that part, I'll
show you a little trick.
What you want to do is
divide this polygon,
the inside of the
polygon, into three
non-overlapping triangles.
And so we could do
that from any side.
Let's say that
they're all coming out
of that side right over there.
So there.
I have divide it-- let me
do this in a neutral color,
I'm doing it in
white-- so that's
one triangle right over here.
And then let me make another
triangle just like that.
So there you go.
I've divided into three
non-overlapping triangles.
And the reason why I
did that, the reason why
this is valuable,
is we know what
the sum of the angles
of a triangle add up to.
And so to make that
useful, we have
to express these angles
in terms of angles
that we can figure
out based on the fact
that the sums of the
angles, or the measures
of the angles in a
triangle add up to 180.
So g is kind of already one
of the angles in the triangle.
F is made up of two
angles in the triangle.
So remember, f is this
entire angle right over here.
So let's divide f
into two other angles,
or two other measures
of angles, I should say.
So let's say that f is equal
to-- we've already gone as high
as, let's see, a,
b, c, d, e, f, g, h,
i, j-- we haven't used k yet.
So let's say that f
is equal to k plus l.
It's equal to the sum of
the measures of these two
adjacent angles right over here.
So f is equal to k plus l.
So that way we've
split it up into angles
of these other triangles.
And then we can do
that with j as well,
because j, once again,
is that whole thing.
So we could that j is equal to--
let's see, we already used l.
So let's say j is
equal to m plus n.
And then finally,
we can split up h.
h is up here.
Remember, it's this whole thing.
Let's say that h is the same
thing as o plus p plus q.
This is o, this is p, this is q.
And once again, I wanted to
split up these interior angles
if they're not already
an angle of a triangle.
I want to split
them up into angles
that are parts of
these triangles.
So we have h is equal
to o, plus p, plus q.
And the reason why
that's interesting
is now we can write the sum
of these interior angles
as the sum of a
bunch of angles that
are part of these triangles.
And then we can use the fact
that, for any one triangle,
they add up to 180 degrees.
So let's do that.
So this expression
right over her
is going to be g. g is
that angle right over here.
We didn't make
any substitutions.
So it's going to
be g-- actually,
let me write the whole thing.
So we have 900 minus,
and instead of a g, well,
actually I'm not
making a substitution,
so I can write g plus,
and instead of an h
I can write that h
is o plus p plus q.
And then plus i.
i is sitting right over there.
Plus i.
And then plus j.
And I kind of messed
up the colors.
The magenta will go with i.
And then j is this
expression right over here.
So j is equal to
m plus n instead
of writing a j right there.
And then finally, we have our f.
And f, we've already seen,
is equal to k plus l.
So plus k plus l.
So once again, I just rewrote
this part right over here,
in terms of these
component angles.
And now something very
interesting is going to happen,
because we know what these
sums are going to be.
Because we know that g plus
k plus o is 180 degrees.
They are the
measures of the angle
for this first
triangle over here,
for this triangle
right over here.
So g plus o plus
k is 180 degrees.
So g-- let me do
this in a new color.
So for this triangle
right over here,
we know that g plus
o plus k are going
to be equal to 180 degrees.
So if we cross those out,
we can write 180 instead.
And then we also know-- let me
see, I'm definitely running out
of colors-- we know that
p, for this middle triangle
right over here, we know that
p plus l plus m is 180 degrees.
So you take those
out and you know
that sum is going to be
equal to 180 degrees.
And then finally, this
is the home stretch here.
We know that q plus n
plus i is 180 degrees
in this last triangle.
Those three are also
going to be 180 degrees.
And so now we know that the
sum of the interior angles
for this irregular
pentagon-- it's actually
going to be true for any
pentagon-- is 180 plus 180
plus 180, which is 540 degrees.
So that whole thing
is 540 degrees.
And if we want to get the
sum of those extra angles,
we just subtract it from 900.
So 900 minus 540 is
going to be 360 degrees.
And we are done.
This is equal to 360 degrees.